the world of gnarnia has captivated
readers since british author CS lewis
launched his seven book chronicles of
narnia series in 1950 with three
live-action film adaptations becoming
worldwide hits however there were some
key differences between the actors cast
in leading roles and the characters as
Lewis described them in the books he is
how the cast of Chronicles of Narnia
should really look for Narnia the white
witch the big villain at the heart of
The Lion the Witch and the Wardrobe at
the White Witch is described as a great
lady taller than any woman that Edmund
had ever seen she also was covered in
white fur up to her throat and held a
long straight golden wand in her right
hand and wore a golden crown on her head
her face was white not merely pale but
white like snow or paper or icing sugar
except for her very red mouth it was a
beautiful face in other respects but
proud and cold and stern that's a pretty
spot-on description of actress Tilda
Swinton's version of the white witch
except she had nude lipstick rather than
that very red mouth Lucy Pevensie the
Pevensie siblings actually got some of
the least detailed descriptions in the
book
perhaps because Lewis wanted children
reading the books to imagine themselves
in the story and see Narnia through
their eyes still there are a few details
that separate the movie children from
the books children beginning with Lucy
in the book Lucy doesn't get a physical
description until she's a grown-up at
which point Lewis says she was always
gay and golden head and all princes in
those parts desired her to be their
queen
actress Georgie Henley has brown hair
which doesn't fit with the description
or the books illustrations which show
Lucy to be a blonde Edmund Pevensie
though access can to Keynes has brown
hair and brown eyes
his character Edmund described in the
books as being blond with blue eyes
the only other physical description
Lewis provides for Edmund comes when
he's betraying his family for the White
Witch his Turkish delight at which point
he says his face had become very red and
his mouth and fingers were sticky he did
not look Eva clever or handsome whatever
the Queen might say
that's small Turkish right now
well Keens the actor is likely clever
and handsome in real life he did a good
job of portraying the Turkish to light
fiend Peter Pevensie oldest sibling
Peter also doesn't get much of a
description until he's an adult
at which point Lois says he is a tall
and a deep chested man and a great
warrior in the books illustrations he's
usually pictured as having brown hair
while William Mosley has dirty blond
locks don't they have hair dye in Narnia
hiking Peter magnificent Susan Pevensie
described by Lewis as the beautiful one
in the family the adult Susan is a tall
and gracious woman with black hair that
fell almost to her feet and the kings of
the countries beyond the sea began to
send ambassadors asking for her hand in
marriage actress Anna Popplewell has
long dark brown hair and although it
doesn't quite reach to her feet
Popplewell does possess the striking
Beauty that Lewis describes for the
character and that fighting spirit sue
mr. Tumnus CS Lewis's dream of the world
of Narnia started with one image a faun
carrying parcels in a snowy wood this
fawn mr. Tumnus understandably gets a
fair amount of description compared to
other characters in the books he was
only a little taller than Lucy herself
and he carried over his head and
umbrella white with snow from the waist
upwards he was like a man
but his legs were shaped like a goat's
the hair on them was glossy black and
instead of feet he had goats hooves
he also had a tail but Lucy did not
notice this at first because it was
neatly caught up over the arm that hold
the umbrella so as to keep it from
trailing in the snow he had a red woolen
muffler around his neck and his skin was
rather reddish too he had a strange but
pleasant little face with a short
pointed beard and curly hair and out of
the hair there stuck two horns
one on each side of his forehead Lewis
later adds that he has brown eyes James
McAvoy's mr. Tumnus has the goat legs
although the hair on them is brown a
rather than glossy black likely to match
McEvoy's natural hair color while he
does have the curly hair Lewis discusses
his skin isn't rather reddish and his
eyes are blue instead of brown still
close enough at least he looks better
than this guy
welcome to Narnia I missed
hey give me back my Shaka goat bastard
hey Prince Caspian like the prevent seas
Prince Caspian doesn't get much of a
description in the voyage of the Dawn
Treader Lewis gives one of his only
details about the prince saying he's a
golden haired boy this doesn't fit with
Ben Barnes dark colored hair in the film
at all but the big difference between
the page in the screen is an age
according to the books Prince Caspian
should be around 13 when the events of
the film take place actor Ben Barnes was
27 and while he could pass for slightly
younger he definitely didn't look like a
teenager so not even close really
Trumpkin Peter Dinklage's Red Dwarf
Trumpkin wasn't quite as red as he was
supposed to be while a Dinklage's
version of the surly character featured
sandy blonde hair the character is
actually described as having an immense
beard and whiskers of coarse red hair
that is rather like a Fox's Lewis also
says that he has twinkling black eyes
not fitting with Dinklage's blue-green
Dinklage does have the beak-like nose
which was added with prosthetics that
were part of the nearly three hour
makeup process for the parts Eustace
Scrubb the first line of the voyage of
the Dawn Treader snarks there was a boy
called Eustace Clarence Scrubb
and he almost deserved it this line is
one of the many ways that Lewis
highlights Eustace his general
intolerable nurse which the author
implies has manifested through his
physical appearance describing him as a
puny little person who couldn't have
stood up even to Lucic actor will
Poulter has experience playing in
software ball characters and he did a
good job of this one he captured Eustace
is persona well especially given the
limited physical characteristics Lewis
provided however he was a little too old
for the part the actor was 16 when the
movie was filmed while Eustace is only
supposed to be 9 while he can pass for
younger than mid-teens the actor still
didn't look quite as young as the
character was supposed to be Aslan Louis
describes Aslan as being a big lion and
sure enough he is just a big old lion
yeah great job thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Applause]